I'm Chris burn I'm an independent toy
analyst and historian I'm here today to
answer your questions from the internet
this is toy
[Music]
support at Addie 915 says why are they
called teddy bears like is it short for
Theodore or what actually the teddy bear
is named for Theodore Roosevelt and in
1905 Teddy Roosevelt refused to shoot a
baby bear on a hunting trip it was
turned into a cartoon Morris mikum of
the ideal toy company saw that he wrote
to Teddy Roosevelt and said can I make
that teddy bear and that's how the teddy
bear came along now that's not the only
story because stif which is a German
plush company also said that they made
teddy bears at the same time so that's
one of those historic conflicts but at
the end of the day the teddy bear is
still named for Theodore Roosevelt at M
tagney says just seen a commercial of a
toy that pooped how do toy makers come
up with these dumb ideas there is
millions of dollars that's been made
with poop toys over the years whether
it's a Magic Toilet where the poop
disappears or it's a pooping dog this is
comedy if you're 3 years old consistent
with the Freudian anal stage as children
are discovering their bodies so for
example when baby alive first came out
Baby Alive was designed to replicate a
real child we'd seen tiny tears that
cried we'd seen Betsy wsy that wet but
suddenly there was a mechanism that
allowed the doll to have solid food put
in and it came out into the diaper so
for a child that was really important
because they were understanding their
bodies at the time but they also got to
nurture in the way that they were being
nurtured in changing the babies it's a
very short road from that to dogs that
poop to monkeys that poop to kangaroos
that poop and poop is funny at Keith L
wants to know how different do
prototypes usually end up being from
final product usually when people are
developing toys they start with two
different models a looks like model
which is often done today with 3D
printing and a works like model which is
a mechanism so when those two things
move together very often that's used as
the basis for the manufacturing so the
Prototype may go through many different
iterations and revisions as you're
getting to the final product but when
you get a final prototype that's almost
the complete toy at Keegan Tindle asks
for ages 18 and up how do they decide
that for toys are they giving it to
younger and younger kids until something
really bad that happens no there are
elaborate testing mechanisms that happen
for kids of all different ages and
because of the way children's bodies
develop you can have a mechanism that
measures the size of a child's uh air
pipe and then when it gets to eight and
up there's also the cognitive
development there is the is my child
intellectually ready for this and so
it's a real good guideline but
definitely for younger kids you want to
pay attention to those age gradings for
what kids can do and what's most safe at
Toby teac wants to know know how can you
use math to design a toy toy design is
almost all engineering so it's almost
all math and you need to figure out the
tolerances of plastic and that's
chemistry and physics put together so
you really need to understand the
different levels of math so that you can
engineer a toy effectively so it'll
stand up under pressure it'll pass
safety regulations and of course it'll
be fun at the 71 Legacy says do kids
still play with action figures yes they
do action figures are huge
this is one of the most iconic action
figures of all time this is Optimus
Prime from Hasbro the term action figure
was actually coined when Hasbro
introduced gii Joe and one of the things
they brought GI Joe to market for was to
be a boy toy that competed with Barbie
which by 1964 was doing pretty well so
any toy really targeting largely a boy
audience based on a TV show or that is a
figure or that's a doll uh is called an
action
figure but then there's also the concept
of the cadal these are adults who are
still collecting action figures they're
the ones who are driving toy lines like
McFarland they're the ones who are
insisting on much more detail in the
Marvel or DC Action Figures so yes
action figures are still a big part of
the toy industry and a big part of
people's lives at Lizzy Bob bizy says
who is Rubik and why do we have his cube
in the 1970s erno Rubik designed Rubik's
Cube as a way of helping to teach math
what was unique about it is the
mechanism inside that allows the cube to
turn in different directions on
different planes very easily and fluidly
Rubik's Cube also became kind of
synonymous with intelligence a kid who
could solve Rubik's Cube and could solve
it fast or could solve it with their
feet was really considered a genius it's
become a phenomenon within the context
of brain puzzles throughout the years
and there have been many other Rubik's
puzzles that have come through the years
at bar stools says how is the pet rock
ever a fad the thing about a fad is
nobody sees it coming nobody can predict
a fad the thing about a pet rock was
that it came at a specific time at a
specific point in our culture it was the
Whimsical nature of the manual that came
with it which is you could teach your
rock to do tricks so it just touched a
nerve I think Johnny Carson had it on
The Tonight Show and it just became this
running gag in the country and that's
how it fact is born at Hall 31 says why
were Beanie Babies popular I don't get
it I don't get it either but they were
beanie babies were introduced in the
'90s but it was really when they came
into the later '90s and the 2000s that
it became collectible and people really
thought as Tai Warner decided to
discontinue some of the Beanie Babies
that they would grow in value so that
peanut The Blue Elephant would be worth
$2,000 a $5.99 toy worth $2,000 that
doesn't really happen very often but
that didn't stop people from believing
it and Beanie Babies created an entire
industry around collecting them we've
seen those kind of phenomenon in history
probably the biggest one was the Tulip
craze in the 17th century when one tulip
bulb would be worth what a family could
make in a year so we really do see this
as happening within human civilization
from time to time you get a craze we
don't know why it happens it takes off
and then it dies at withered BB film
says I will never understand how
Transformer toys are designed especially
in such high numbers the really amazing
thing about Transformers I'm going to
bring my friend Optimus back in here for
this these were originally made by
Takara and it was all about robots
transforming it was a very Japanese
concept it's really an engineering tour
to force when they do all of these the
different plastic pieces that fit
together and fold up this one
particularly is is done with a process
called injection molding so you have two
halves of a mold and literally what
happens is when it's in the machine
liquid plastic is shot into the mold and
it takes on the shapes you see here
that's why precise molding is really
important and molds are very expensive
molds also have a life cycle so they
have to keep redoing them so it really
is a way of getting the plastic into a
shape but with Transformers it's doubly
hard because not only do you get into
the shape but it has to move in a
specific way and there's not a lot of
room for mistakes in this at Chloe
Sullivan PR says imagine what kids toys
will be like in 50 years time I don't
think it's too difficult to imagine that
because children don't change that much
as a species we don't evolve quite that
fast the toys will reflect things that
are going on in the culture but we'll
still need the basics for developing I
hand coordination developing gross motor
skills interacting socially what's
changed toys really in the last 40 years
has been the evolution of chips so for
example the original Furby had the same
chip in it that powered the Apple 2
computer as chips get more and more
sophisticated you're going to see the
toys able to do more and the big
question in 2023 is how is AI going to
impact toy design at sank 64 says
whenever I watch Disney and see
commercials for toys I think all of
these toys are plastic how are toy
companies creating more sustainable toys
or at least recyclable toys the most
sustainable toy is the one that never
gets thrown out something like Lego is
completely sustainable because it gets
passed down from Kid to Kid how ever
there are a lot of experiments going on
with toys made from sustainable
materials there's a lot of wood coming
in toys and then because plastic is
endemic to toys you're also seeing
things like less packaging companies
reducing the lights in their Factor so
it's highly highly considered in toy
companies right now and they're looking
to see what the next best practice is at
lonard nout says also how does Lego do
quality control how is every single
piece piece perfect and how do you never
miss a piece from the set it's amazing
the thing about Lego is that they have
an entire company dedicated to just that
to Quality Control to the kind of ABS
plastic that they use to the way in
which the pieces fit together and stay
together to the way in which things are
designed they have an entire model shop
that tries these things out and it
really is their brand identity at pae
says I'm so interested in recalled toys
it's so interesting like I honestly kind
of want that one rollerblade Barbie from
1993 where her skates literally have
lighters in them so they spark when she
moves you might want that and you might
be able to find it but it probably
wasn't safe toy recalls are actually
rare because toys go through such
comprehensive testing before they ever
go to market but every once in a while
something comes through there's a part
that's not right or there's different
things that happened to it when I was
working with CBS toys we had a creative
play things wooden gym the steps on the
ladder were too close together so if a
child stuck their head in it we never
thought they would it could actually get
stuck so you recall that so you can fix
that part and then reissue the toy at
chill Candace says the real question is
how did Hasbro make so much money off a
potato head that's crazy who would have
thought a potato would be a classic toy
lol it was one of the First toys to be
advertised on television probably nobody
in 1952 when it first came out the
original Mr Potato Head just had the
body and on top of the body was a spike
and that Spike you Ed to impale a real
potato on and then you decorated it with
eyes nose mouth pipe it was something
that if Captain Kangaroo had it on it
was going to be a phenomenon because at
the time almost every kid in America was
watching Captain Kangaroo but it was
really something that caught the
imagination of kids at Blue Dragon 211
says I remember but how many remember
the Cabbage Patch doll chaos of 19 1983
Cabbage Patch dolls in 1983 became so
popular because they really made that
amazing transition that happens every
once in a while when you go from a toy
designed for kids to a cultural
phenomenon by Xavier Roberts they were
original Appalachian artwork they were
kind of inspired by Apple dolls and then
when kico got them they made them with
plastic faces one of the things that
made Cabbage Patch dolls unique was that
you didn't own it you adopted it and
each Doll came with adoption papers that
you had to fill out and send back into
the toy company it was the scarcity and
the fact that trying to find them that
really drove the phenomenon so having it
became as important as playing with it
at J Hamlet wants to know has any
business ever taken advantage of Rights
licensing across every genre more
effectively than Funko Pop it's
startling just how deep they go that's
absolutely true for somebody who might
not be familiar with Funko Pop they
really came out of the whole Urban vinyl
movement which started in Japan and it
it was all about Collectibles based on
either anime figures or entertainment
figures Funko Pop has a very unique look
it's got the larger head the smaller
body and when you look at it you know
that's a Funko Pop That made it perfect
for licensing so you can interpret
Mickey Mouse you can interpret Harry
Potter you can interpret pretty much
anything share if you want to and the
one thing it has in common is everybody
knows it's Funko at Lily Bailey UK says
tell me how old you are by telling me
your favorite toy fat well it's right
here it's Mr machine in 1960 this
transformed the toy industry you could
extensively take aart and put back
together you wound him up he was so
popular every kid had to have him the
whole appeal of taking apart Mr machine
was that robots were very popular during
the 50s and in popular entertainment the
problem was kids would get it apart they
couldn't get it back together and guess
what it didn't come with instructions to
put it back together at dgn mree says I
wonder how toy collectors decide what to
keep in box and what to unbox if you are
hoping that your toy is going to
appreciate and value you're going to
leave it in the box and you're going to
have to take care of that box too
because the state of the Box does
contribute to the value of the toy every
once in a while you'll come across a
mint inbox 1959 Barbie and that's worth
about $6,000 depending on where you get
it but then I always ask what happened
to the child at Terry Bradshaw says is
there anyone here that collects
McDonald's toys from the Happy Meal I'm
sure it's worth something collecting
Happy Meal toys or any fast food toys is
a huge subset of the toy industry you
will find conventions you will find
collectors you will find websites they
really do have a value within that
Community I have two versions here of
Woody that came with the Burger King
meals in 1995 when it came out and it
was a phenomenon these are still very
rare and highly collectible and I'm not
going to open them because that would
diminish their value at jrn Merchant
wants to know how does one get into the
toy industry specifically toy design
asking for a friend I love this question
because one of the things the toy
industry needs desperately is more
designers so there are two great
programs one at Fashion Institute of
Technology in New York and then one at
Otis College of design in Los Angeles
now you don't necessarily need to go to
college to be able to do this a lot of
people have industrial design
backgrounds a lot of people have
animation backgrounds and really it's
about team and bringing your unique
skills to the table that's all the
questions hope you learned something fun
about toys until next
time